au soir tout le monde on ce soir ce soir
je dois dire que joli programme pour
vous en effet je dois vous annoncer une
soirée littéraire l'époque
j'adore les récits de sion est alors
voila mon premier poème paye mais qu'est
ce qu'ils fument comme ça dans le studio
trion excuse mais je savais pas que la
fumée te dérange pas c'est je passe à
jouer edward parce qu'on m'a dit que tu
étais tellement charmante et touche tant
m je vois tous les soirs dans ma loge
seulement je veux dire je voulais voir
de près j'aime pas que tu étais bleus
passaient les téléspectateurs il situe
savent que bleus n'ont ici tout le sait
que je suis blanche mais le bleu c'est
pour la télé noir c'est que c'est normal
que tu devrais te même aimé la pile toi
quand même enfin propagera pas bien sa
bague des douits jc est maintenue alors
s'il te plait pas je m'excuse mais tu
sais je suis c'est presque par contrat
que je fume la pipe de ce pays que si
mais non ma m'engager maigret ben voilà
dis moi tu me disais justement tout à
l'heure tu me vois tous les soirs dans
sa loge
oui et non tu est partout à la fois tu
es à la fois dans les studios sur les
écrans au théâtre en tournée avec le
cirque qu'est ce que c'est que ce atp
retour à la fois toi tu as dit gym au
jeu trash ce jeu trash cette loi est le
théâtre c'est mon bon moment de la
journée c'est comme si j'allais prendre
l'apéritif stoessel terre ferme au
billard au café du commerce
mais alors comment peux-tu à la fois
s'occuper du cirque et de tourner une
émission de télévision mais tu sais
jamais fatigué à skis ce qui importe
c'est faire des choses qui t'amuse
guahma voilà moi je pourrais pas faire
une chose qui me plaît pas batiactu voit
d'ailleurs en plus à la télévision ils
sont très gentils recevant champlain
dans un me grey je suis en fait c'est à
dire qu'on vient de finir les intérieurs
on va commencer extérieur et claude
barma balle et ses dix jours m'occuper
du départ du cirque
alors je suis encore encore un petit peu
meilleur avec la pipe mais je m'occupe
surtout en ce moment du cirque qui va
prendre la route dans dans quelques
jours
citant saint cirq qui s'en va sur la
route de valmont série 90 voitures à la
fois 90 voitures c'est la joie c'est la
joie des automobilistes quand il croise
un cirque trois mois autant fait pas je
suis sûr que quand il voit ton nom sur
les voitures qu'elles se disant c'est un
copain mais si mais si le tour de france
naturellement à tour de france combien
nous allons pas pour preuve peut-être
toute l'année puisque après on va à
l'étranger
si quelque chose parle-moi de maigret
maintenant il va très bien on les forme
pendant tout en ayant et puis trois
autres après tu vois je m'aime je vais
me faire un maigret cet été aux endroits
où sera le cirque ça avoue que chaque
chose sinon j'avoue que ses loyers
calculé c'est un rôle écrit pour un
crime ou un drame au cirque quelque
chose je vois ça d'ici et à leur père le
mois du sommet si tu utilises tu viens
aux jo je peux je peux pas te faire une
caserne si je te laisse en liberté tu
vas te faire bouffer par les bêtes plus
grosse que toi ça c'est bien vrai oui
mais alors que maintenant tu une grande
vedette si un jour tu es livre si la
télévision tu laisses des moments de
liberté tu pourrais venir présenter un
spectacle de cirque mais ça je vais te
dire à faire faire une tournée sous
chapiteau tu sais que c'est un rêve
oui j'adore ses envies les caravanes
j'adore l'extrême orient c'est
merveilleux autre chose la publicité tu
as fait de la publicité naturellement tu
fais tout toi non je vois plus est très
visité si je suis en train d'en faire
publicité à cause de mes gars imagina
samedi soir si on voit vendre à huit
heures du soir si on me voit vendre de
la lessive des nouilles ou de l'huile
comment veux tu es après qu'on puisse
imaginer que maigret puisse diriger une
enquête alors qu'il a vendu savent pas
possible ça évidemment ça ferait double
vie tout de suite mais en tout cas la
publicité tu regardes ça oui j'en
regarde alors ya là qu'il a fait crouch
crochet qui m'a fait confiance tout
allait bien
les all blacks et ensemble juste pour te
donner des idées pour voir ce que c'est
nous allons regarder la publicité turbo
qu'est ce que tu vas me rendre